و خلال تجمع جماهيري للحزب الديمقراطيسي
في ولايه ميلان لاند قال الرئيس الامريكي
جو ايضا نادي الديمقراطيه الامريكيه معرضه
للخطر ويجب الدفاع عنها من ان العنف
السياسيه والترهيب يتزايدان في جميع انحاء
الولايات المتحده
في الاسبوع الماضي فان الديمقراطيه في
ورقه الاقتراع
ويتزاد العنف سياسي والترهيب في جميع
انحاء البلاد تتذكرون حين مقترحمته
الغاضبه مبنى الكونجرس وهجمت اجهزه الامن
وطاردت المسؤولين المنتخبين و نصبت حبل
المشنقه لنائب الرئيس السابق
هناك اكثر من 300 مرشح جمهوريه هذا العام
يشككون في الانتخابات ويحاولون حرمانا
الناخبين من الاقتراع وبعدم اصواتهم
فرق شغل ابدا الرئيس الامريكي جوبايدا
ايضا تفائله بشان فرص حزبه الى الحفاظ على
الاغلبيه في مجلسين نواب والشيوخ خلال
الانتخابات النصفيه التي ستجرى اليوم
الثلاثاء
ستمضي للامام بغض النظر عن ما سيحدث في
الانتخابات
على تصويت بشكل مبكر مشيرا الى ان لدى
الديمقراطيين ليله اخرى لبذل ما في وسعهم
للفوز بالانتخابات ووصف
الدائمه بانها واحده اكثر من مجموعات
الظلاميه في البلاد ولا تمثل الاباء
المؤسسين للحزب الجمهوري حسب تعبير